avec nicolas vidal directeur de la
publication directeur de publication de
putsch médias bonsoir nicolas vidal
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
nous n'avons pas à rougir de notre bilan
a dit le chef de l'état vous êtes
d'accord alors emmanuel m'apprendre il a
fait un quatrième à qu'il a délaissé la
moraline emmanuel macron pour une auto
satisfaction des gens qui ne doute
absolument de rien ça c'est pour en
préambule et puis alors moi ce soir j'ai
frétiller très sincèrement sur mon
canapé parce que j'ai entendu plusieurs
fois le mot indépendance france
indépendante et ça j'ai trouvé dès le
début qu'on avait quelque chose de
novateur d'un discours des manuels
macron bien entendu le pessimisme ne m'a
rattrapé immédiatement donc pour revenir
sur ce point indépendance et en entendu
économie souveraine écologique louer les
terres en semi de l'état les
relocalisations les investissements dans
l'économie
tout ça finalement on a senti qu'il y
avait une volonté de remettre la france
au centre du jeu mais vous savez magali
c'est toujours le en même temps avec
manuel macron donc attendre nous a
resservi le réchauffé du micron de
l'union européenne avec vous savez
toujours ces grands panégyrique de
l'union européenne forte europe
solidaire souveraine sociale tout ce
qu'on entend en permanence donc emmanuel
macron il revient finalement sur cette
idée par du en même temps parce que je
pense que c'est ça qui est central
aujourd'hui dans ce discours pour moi
selon mon avis c'est cette idée toujours
de l'ambivalence permanence et on verra
sur le plan de la relance pour en dire
quelques mots
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu d'annoncé
énorme là dessus ça a été tout a été
très conceptuel par rapport à emmanuel
macron qu'un cran mais on est vraiment
sous une nouvelle danse de la pluie vous
savez une espèce de grande sécheresse
aride de ceux de cette crise économique
absolument redoutable qu'on est en train
de voir venir et je crois que manuel
macron voilà sur ce discours là c'était
vraiment encore le en même temps aux
permanences alors il n'y a pas eu
d'annoncé concrète
effectivement à part le passage de la
métropole en tout cas en zone verte dès
demain la vie doit doit reprendre les
français doivent retrouver leur liberté
a dit le chef de l'état ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour vous ben oui
forcément je vais vous dire que
personnellement et nous toutes et nous
tous a envie de reprendre une vie
normale mais il faut toujours accéder ce
qui va se passer
donc quelques jours il ya déjà la manif
des soignants il ya toute une vraie mode
au social et populaire qui a encore la
de plus en plus lourdes en france est
une nouvelle fois je le dis c'est que
cette politique en permanence de se
tourner vers l'europe pour nous par
d'accords historiques avec l'allemagne
je suis pas aussi optimiste qui manuel
macro on nous refait le coup du couple
franco-allemand qui est pour moi un
couple virtuel un parce que salo
masochiste à moment donné on peut pas
toujours se tourner par union européenne
et je crois que la souveraineté
économique à souveraineté sanitaires on
l'a vu avec la crise des masques on l'a
vu avec les tests on l'a vu avec le nom
fermeture des frontières
il n'ya que finalement nos souverainetés
qui aurait pu au moins paris ce virus
rappelez-vous magali quand emmanuel
macron à l'échelle européenne disait il
ya que l'europe finalement qui peut le
protéger de la chine de l'inde du brésil
états unis
on s'est rendu compte une nouvelle fois
que l'union européenne nous a protégés
d'absolument de personnes et que tout le
monde a fermé ses frontières s'est
claquemuré sur son territoire sa
souveraineté pour essayer de faire face
comme on a pu donc concrètement une
nouvelle fois on ouvre aussi qu'une
logis rappelez-vous ans le 16 mars ont
déjà fait en mars emmanuel macron à ce
premier acte nous avait parlé qu'il
fallait se réinventer il fallait voir la
mondialisation sous notre jour
aujourd'hui on nous ressert absolument
la même tambouille néolibérale et la
réforme des retraites n'est pas à
première vue abandonné par emmanuel
macron donc vous voyez moi j'ai pas
l'impression que ça a changé si ce n'est
qu'après qu'on va en parler de ses
déclarations sur la france qui se
dérouleront en a pas que je veuille
n'ira pas son histoire ça sincèrement on
va en parler effectivement je voudrais
qu'on écoute d'abord le chef de l'état
sur qui a admis quelques faiblesses
néanmoins bien sûr cette épreuve a aussi
révélé des failles des fragilités notre
dépendance à d'autres continents pour
nous procurer certains produits non
lourdeur d'organisation nos inégalités
sociales et territoriales
je veux que nous tirions toutes les
leçons de ce que nous avons vécu est
avec vous
comprendre ce que nous avons mieux
réussi au moins bien réussi que nos
voisins nos forces nous les
confronterons nos faiblesses nous les
corrigerons vite et fort où il va
falloir tirer toutes les leçons est ce
que pour vous il ya déjà une esquisse de
ces leçons à tirer par le chef de l'état
dans son discours ce soir mais on en est
toujours à déclaration d'intention avec
man
macron parce qu'on n'arrive pas à faire
la synthèse effectivement avec ça mais
je ne crois pas faits sont là tirer mes
gens pareils en préambule il ya une
espèce de satisfaction on peut pas nier
les énormes et roman énorme énorme
erreur que l'état français sur les
masses notamment à des tests et même sur
les lits d'hôpitaux sont toujours
rappeler que c'est la france
périphérique qui a sorti le pays en
partie de ce bourbier on rappellera les
soignants qui sont à leur première ligne
donc finalement c'est la résidence alors
je reprends en encontre plutôt le terme
d' emmanuel macron la résidence mais la
région celle est venue de quoi elle est
venue de l'essence même de la france de
la france périphérique l'état était
totalement dépassé sur cette crise alors
on nous dit oui tous les pays ont été
frappées
oui mais à un moment donné on n'avait
pas aussi des armes pour lutter
efficacement contre ce virus ou du moins
l'endiguer plus tôt et plus fort et plus
vite dans - une nouvelle fois c'est
toujours de la grande déclaration
d'intention avec cette espèce de
panégyrique du en même temps et ça ça
n'a jamais sorti un pays de dafra
économique dans lequel la bise
économique dans lequel nous sommes en
train de voir propulser précipitée alors
le chef de l'état qui a condamné
également le racisme tout en saluant le
rôle des forces de l'ordre en france
rôle essentiel selon le chef de l'état
bien sûr qu'il a dit aussi que on
n'allait pas à déboulonner des statuts
et qu'il fallait garder et ne pas rougir
non plus deux des identités des oreilles
des autres qu'en pensez vous alors venue
de macron oui c'est une phrase forte est
pas débouler les statuts panier notre
histoire
paris l'histoire ou la remontée certes
très bien jusqu'à là on peut lui
accorder un peu de légitimité mais je
vous rappelle qu emmanuel macron en pré
campagne à lyon dans un discours il avec
annie qui n'existait pas de culture
française qui avait une culture
française pluriel donc emmanuel macron
il apparaît toujours le même sentiment
sur ce qui la culture française
l'identité française
donc ça c'est extrêmement important et
puis une nouvelle fois je pense du
manuel macron pour moi c'est pas un
président république c'est un
gestionnaire
on l'a vu deux
de l'union européenne vont faire très
vite pour passer là dessus et finalement
le problème a mis tellement des
fractures très important pour grand jour
qu'il ne peut pas faire autrement
aujourd'hui que de réagir sur ce point
mais je crois que là-dessus emmanuel
macron il est un peu faible sur les
pattes arrière alors il a fait il a été
père en toi aujourd'hui sur l'histoire
française est une nouvelle fois c'est
assez novateur dans son discours mais je
prends une mode que c'est vraiment la
déclaration d'intention et on verra si
c'est suivi d'effet rappelez-vous le
discours serait laïcité notamment sur un
thème beaucoup plus large
on l'attend toujours ce grand discours
donc moi pour l'instant je n'accorde
aucun crédit émis deux points de
confiance tous acquis emmanuel macron
c'est une histoire de points il nous
fera un gros 1 points en juillet et vous
savez aujourd'hui les l'histoire des
points en français la réforme des
retraites est très à la mode chez manuel
da cruz
merci beaucoup nicolas vidal pour votre
analyse merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france ce soir